yes we finally got confirmation that
apple is working on a lower cost apple
tv that is going to be launching in the
second half of this year and i am
personally excited because the current
apple tv options are pretty pricey over
a hundred and fifty dollars so what i'm
gonna do in this video is go through all
of the leaks including what i think this
apple tv is gonna be how much it's gonna
cost and exactly when it is going to
launch so without further ado this leak
comes from ming chi kuo who is a
reputable leaker and he's actually from
taiwan so he has a lot of sources in
terms of the supply chain but earlier
this morning he said that apple will
launch a new version of the apple tv
that improves the cost structure in the
second half of 2022
and his reasoning for it is because
apple's aggressive strategy of
integrating hardware content and service
amid the recession will help close the
gap with its competitors yes mingshukol
believes that we are currently in a
recession and i'm sure you guys have
seen the headlines all over the news
kathy wood thinking that we're in a
global recession right now as well as
many other analysts and i personally
think we are as well at least in some
european countries china and probably
the united states right now and i
actually made a video about that
explaining all of the details so
definitely check that out and because i
think we're currently going through a
recession i think that apple really
needs to pivot their strategy and stop
selling such expensive apple tv hardware
and bring it down a bit because their
apple tv plus streaming service has
really been picking up a lot of steam
especially with shows like severance
which was such an amazing show
especially the finale and i think it's
my favorite show ever since breaking bad
which was a masterpiece now of course
apple is gonna be losing money on the
apple tv hardware because currently the
cheapest apple tv hd model you can buy
is a hundred and fifty dollars so if
they drop the price they're gonna lose
money in terms of the hardware however i
think they're gonna make much more money
back in terms of subscriptions like with
their apple tv plus or with people
getting apple arcade as well or even
with the apple one deal right now which
is actually a really good deal for 20
bucks for an entire family getting tv
plus arcade plus icloud and apple music
for the family that's just insane i
think that is where apple is gonna make
the money back if they make a cheaper
apple tv so with that said what is the
best way to do this well i personally
think that apple is gonna be working on
an apple tv 4k streaming stick yes a
streaming stick now that might sound
insane but there are a lot of different
tv sticks out there right now including
the amazon fire tv and i think it's
going to be competing directly with this
one as well as the other ones on the
market now if you didn't already know we
actually had some leaks and rumors years
ago about apple creating a tv stick and
that was confirmed by the information
with an exclusive report saying that
apple considered a new apple tv dongle
basically a streaming tv stick but
unfortunately a couple years after that
it was reported that apple abandoned the
low-cost tv dongle plan and apparently
there was actually a project driven by
tim tour doll an apple video and audio
marketing executive who argued that a
low-cost tv device would make it more
affordable for users to access tv plus
based on his experience overseeing
similar projects at netflix and amazon
but unfortunately greg joswiak and phil
schiller overruled him saying that apple
didn't want to make cheaper lower margin
devices because of its potential to
damage its reputation for premium
products and because of that the
low-cost tv device project was abandoned
well now
i think that since we're going into a
recession at least i think we are i
think it makes sense for apple to pivot
over to the cheaper tv device and let
their services really thrive and in that
way they can compete with the massive
market of the amazon fire tv stick 4k
look at that
thousand ratings apple would be entering
a huge market here and they would be
selling a lot of those tv plus
subscriptions and at the same time i
think apple is gonna discontinue the old
apple tv hd because it's outdated and
for 150 it's not really a good deal so
they're gonna completely scrap that and
then they're probably gonna update the
higher end apple tv 4k maybe give it a
different name and give it a newer chip
maybe the a15 or maybe even the m1 chip
and just really focus on the performance
maybe even for gaming but now the main
question we have to answer is how much
is this new tv dongle going to cost and
i personally think it's going to be
priced at around 80 bucks which might
sound cheap in terms of being an apple
tv but i think it could totally make
sense and let me explain why first of
all i think it's going to be wi-fi only
so there's no longer going to be an
ethernet port so it's going to be a
smaller dongle and that is going to help
apple save cost at least on the hardware
bits and in terms of the actual chip
that's going to be inside of it i
personally think it makes sense for them
to probably keep the same a12 which is a
decent deal for 80 bucks or they might
even upgrade to the a13 which is quite a
bit more powerful and it's more
efficient but who really knows either
way it's gonna be a pretty good deal for
80 bucks now because i think it's going
to be pretty small portable slim and
with an efficient chip i think that it
could potentially be powered through a
tv's usb port and include a mount for
the back of your tv and this would
basically allow the apple tv dongle to
work without needing to be plugged into
the wall at all which would be a game
changing feature and if anybody does it
i think apple will and the reason i
think that makes so much sense is
because mac rumors recently posted a
video in an article showing off a new
product that costs 25
which basically allows you to power a
full apple tv yes the full big box
directly from your tv's usb port and
believe it or not this actually works
right now with the apple tv and it's
going to be much easier with the new tv
dongle so i think it makes total sense
and if you didn't already know apple
already sells a third-party mounting kit
for the apple tv which includes a
charger for the remote that uses the
tv's usb port so apple is already okay
with selling this third-party mount and
it's probably giving them good ideas
about the tv dongle that i think is
coming now in my opinion the reason that
apple is going to be able to price this
new tv dongle at 80 bucks and still make
good money is because i think the new
siri remote for 59
is no longer gonna be included so you're
gonna purchase it separately if you want
to and that instantly cuts 60 bucks from
the price which makes it very easy to
sell the new tv dongle at 80 bucks and
who knows maybe it's gonna be lower and
you might think i'm crazy for not
including the siri remote however the
iphone actually has a tv remote app
built in as you can see so basically
apple could sell that new budget tv
dongle and advertise that you can use
your iphone as the remote so that way
you never lose it or whatever and if you
really want a physical nice controller
or remote you just buy the siri remote
and i also believe that since wwdc is
coming very soon i think apple could
redesign or upgrade the features with
that new tv remote app for the iphone as
well as redesign the apple tv software
tv os and that would make everything a
lot better for the new tv dongle and
then of course just like the current
apple tv it's going to support basically
everything that you can do on this older
model but this time it's going to
support 4k content it's going to support
apple tv plus it's going to support all
the games and probably all the other
streaming apps including netflix disney
plus hbo max and everything else at a
lower cost 80 dollar apple tv dongle but
with that said i think apple is going to
use this opportunity to also introduce a
brand new product yes i think apple is
going to introduce a new gaming
controller accessory for the iphone 4
gaming which i made a video about and
within that video there were actual
patents by apple showing off a nintendo
switch style controller that would
attach to the sides of your iphone and
also use magsafe to connect so i covered
all of that in this video but the really
big deal about that new controller
accessory is that i think it's going to
work for the apple tv it's going to work
for macs like the macbook pro and it's
also potentially going to work to
control your ipad as well and finally
the last question we got gotta answer is
when this new lower cost apple tv is
going to come well ming chi ko says the
second half of 2022 so because of that i
think we're gonna get an event in
october or november and apple could
potentially prepare some new gaming
content as well as apple arcade plus
maybe some aaa games and that new gaming
accessory controller for the iphone and
that is going to be a big deal if they
package everything up into one event and
that's really going to help push sales
of the lower cost apple tv as well so
with that said hopefully you enjoyed
this video and if you disagree with any
of my thoughts let me know down in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
the video click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]
you